do you think there should be a cap on
income yes fully uh what we're looking
at is surfton what percentage should be
paid by the top one percent probably 60
70 or 80 percent i think if they could
kick it up to 75 to 80 that would be
good man hit them up for
they need to be freaking taxed what's
wrong with 90
90 is i like you i love you man ninety
percent
this ninety percent ninety-five percent
dude they live on five percent i think
they can live on five percent man i get
where you're going with this man i i
totally agree 99 of their wealth why
should people with less money be paying
more than billionaires when they
literally don't have that money to pay
in the first place i mean truly this
makes me sad for democracy what do you
think that people who are richer than
you should pay everything 120 of their
wealth why should they have more money
than i am i mean here i am in the middle
of the day in a park
i assume this is a work day
maybe they have more money than you
because they're not walking around in a
park in the middle of the day maybe hmm